two boar attacks two very different
outcomes here's how a scene in house of
the dragon had fans thinking back to the
first season of game of thrones
much of the third episode of house of
the dragon revolves around a rather
pathetic royal stag hunt in the
kingswood and king viserys's troubles
regarding matters of family and
succession princess rhaenyra targaryen
is technically traveling with the king
but wants absolutely nothing to do with
the staged hunt let alone the clumsy and
self-serving social activities around it
making it even less appealing is lord
jason lannister of casterly rock who is
aspiring to win her hand in marriage
thank you for the wine
rhaenyra chooses to distance herself
from the proceedings by taking a ride in
the woods accompanied by her hand-picked
kingsguard member sir kristen cole their
stay in the forest ends up going on
quite a bit longer than anyone but
rhaenyra is comfortable with and even
includes a brief encounter with a
majestic stag that's markedly different
from viserys's experience but it's
another notable incident during rhaenyra
and sir kristen's forest jaunt that
brings an entirely different and much
later king to mind as princess rhaenyra
and sir kristen are hanging out in the
forest a mysterious noise from the
bushes prompts them to investigate the
source of the sound turns out to be an
extremely disgruntled wild boar which
charges kristen and sends the knight
flying the boar then attempts to attack
and gore ray nera but fortunately the
pair manages to kill the animal in the
nick of time game of thrones fans will
immediately remember another time a boar
attacked a royal in the woods king
robert baratheon is grievously wounded
when a boar attacks him during a hunting
expedition that also takes place in the
kingswood this is an incredibly
important event since robert's death
leads to the arrest and execution of ned
stark and sets the stage for the bloody
succession conflict that fuels the rest
of the series while there are obvious
similarities between the borah attacks
and house of the dragon and game of
thrones there are also very clear
differences the boar attack in game of
thrones is a highly shady affair as the
lannisters have made sure that robert
had plenty to drink the night before the
hunt the attack itself also happens off
screen between episodes as if to
underscore the highly underwhelming
nature of king robert's rule
my fault
too much wine
missed my thrust the boar scene in house
of the dragon happens fully on screen
and the end result of the terrifying
encounter couldn't be more different
either while robert dies a sad
contemplative death in bed while making
a hasty attempt to set his affairs in
order and right past wrongs rhaenyra
rides back to the hunting party with the
dead bore in tow looking more regal than
ever and drawing odd and admiring looks
from everyone who sees her the effect of
rhaenyra bagging a dangerous boar with
just one night is further enhanced by
the fact that many of the people present
just saw her father's bungling attempts
to put a stag out of its misery despite
the fact that people were literally
holding it for him to stab so when
robert meets zabor his rule and his life
comes to a pitiful end rhaenyra
encounters one and not only lives to
tell the tale but gains bucket loads of
respect that'll surely prove worth its
weight in gold going forward
[Music]